[Musique]
vous
le christ
oh
[Musique]
absents
sur le
[Musique]
je ne sais pas
oui
[Musique]
il est 18h15 vous écoutez la première et
on vous en remercie lundi politique
gaël le dantec combien de temps et on
jeune en politique notre invité est
souvent présenté comme il représentants
de la jeunesse en politique elle n'est
pourtant plus dans les instances jeunes
de son parti elle est aujourd'hui passée
chez les grands chais des seniors elle
est même devenue porte parole de son
parti de la fédération réunionnaise du
parti socialiste elle est aujourd'hui
élu au conseil municipal de saint denis
elle est passée pas loin d'intérêt pour
ces départementale et devrait remplacer
michel dennemont au sénat dans deux ans
selon les termes d'un accord entre le
parti socialiste et le lpa lors des
élections sénatoriales de l'an dernier
ancien attaché parlementaire de monique
orphé notre invité fait partie de ces
militants ou élus du parti socialiste
qui ont préféré un temps macro hamon
pourtant la semaine dernière elle signe
un soutien à pierrick robert dans
l'élection législative partielle au
motif qu'il s'opposait à la politique du
gouvernement
nous tenterons d'y voir un peu plus
clair dans son positionnement politique
audrey bel hymne est l'invité de lundi
politique jusqu'à 19 heures une émission
que vous pouvez suivre également en
vidéo sur notre site internet lundi
politique de gaël le dantec aux
rébellions soir bonsoir
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
hier jean luc poudroux que ça a été du
député la réunion va t'en pierrick
robert avec près de 60% des suffrages
exprimés
quel regard qu'elle vous portez sur
cette élection législative partielle
dans la 7e circonscription
mais avant tout le premier regard c'est
l'abstention qui l'y a eu sur ces
élections avec à peine 30% de deux taux
de participation c'est c'est un message
fort que nous envoie encore une fois la
population en s'abstenant de participer
à la vie politique
c'est le message que l'on doit retenir
nos politiques cette abstention
on va on va y revenir dans un instant
vous sur l'élection elle-même vous aviez
appelé à voter pour pierrick robert le
candidat du npa on aurait pu penser que
c'était par proximité centristes on va
revenir sur l'accord lpa ps mais c'est
plutôt son opposition à la politique des
moyens macron que vous avez souligné
tout à fait effectivement
le lpa s'est engagé au travers d'un
communiqué à s'opposer en tout cas à la
politique d' emmanuel macron et c'est en
cela aussi du fait qu'il est un parti
progressiste c'est aussi pour cela qu'il
a choisi donc de soutenir cette
candidature est donc de d'éliminer la
candidature donc de monsieur poudre
hooks qui finalement incarner la droite
de didier robert mais aussi du aussi
s'oppose à la politique macro tout à
fait donc nous sur notre positionnement
local
si vous voulez on va on va tout d'abord
peut-être parler du premier tour nous
avions eu finalement cette possibilité
de choisir au premier tour donc nous
avons lavés pas présenter de candidat
nous n'avons pas qu'on se présenter de
candidat puisque vous savez lorsque
lorsque la gauche et est éparpillé elle
ne gagne pas et les électeurs ne se
retrouvent pas là dedans donc nous
avions anticipé nous avions réfléchi à
cela et nous avions décidé de nous
positionner en faveur d' emmanuel
séraphin en pensant que les autres
partis de gauche les autres partis
progressif puissent aller dans cette
même direction
cela n'a pas été le cas malheureusement
et nous voyons bien que lorsque la
gauche était par pie ix et elle ne gagne
pas donc ça nous a donné donc la
possibilité de ce premier tour de
choisir et donc dans le deuxième tour
nous devions donc éliminé vous avez
parlé avec le plr avec emmanuel séraphin
de ce soutien au deuxième tour écoutez
la fédération s'est engagée elle a
discuté effectivement du second tour
je ne pense pas qu'il faille contre
qu'on se prononce sur ce positionnement
face au plr il nous fallait nous en tant
que parti en tant que responsable
politique et aussi du fait de cette
abstention record
cette forte abstention il fallait que
nous prenions nos responsabilités et
nous ne pouvions pas ne pas appeler à
voter puisque nous voulons vaincre cette
abstention
donc il était important pour nous mais
de se positionner et de favoriser en
tout cas les candidats qui sont dans
l'opposition d' emmanuel macron et qui
n'incarne surtout pas la droite de
didier robert
audrey bel hymne qu'est ce que vous
pensez l'attitude de thierry robert qui
n'a pas payé ses impôts notamment
l'impôt sur la fortune dans les temps et
qui a donc été déclaré inéligible par le
conseil constitutionnel et qui
site de présenter son frère en disant
c'est que voter pour lui c'est comme si
c'était voter pour moi je si je peux me
permettre un je ne suis pas le lpa je ne
suis pas au lpa le choix du candidat le
leur appartient et je pense que c'est
une question à laquelle thierry robert
pourra mieux répondre que moi qu'est-ce
que je n'ai pas vous emporte ce n'est
pas ce que j'en pense c'est son choix je
ne vais pas venir discuter des choix de
thierry robert par rapport aux candidats
qu'ils souhaitaient soutenir non mais
quand il voulait pour lui c'est voter
pour moi c'est la même chose
malheureusement ça n'a pas forcément
fonctionner peut-être je ne souhaite pas
vraiment commenter cela puisque comme il
faut que l'on sait c'est vraiment une
décision qui appartient au lpa et pas à
nous donc maintenant les électeurs ont
rejeté cette décision
je pense qu'il de kiltir à
l'enseignement de cela également
mais ce n'est pas à nous parti
socialiste fédération du parti
socialiste d'avoir à commenter le choix
de son candidat
est ce que le fait que thierry robert a
été sanctionnée par le conseil
constitutionnel ça modifie vos rapports
avec le beurre écoutez nous menons
rapport ils sont fixés donc autant des
échéances électorales
nous avions eu une première négociation
ultérieurement nous en avons une là sur
la 7ème circo et je pense qu'il faut
qu'on s'arrête à la jeu je ne pense pas
qu'il faille tout de suite tirer des
conclusions de deux sets
votre rigueur vous ferai pas de
commentaire sur la façon dont thierry
robert s'est comporté en tant que député
que ce soit dans cette campagne
aulas sans ménagement en tout cas je ne
souhaite pas faire de commentaires là
dessus je ne je ne je ne pense pas que
ce ça cela soit ma place de vous
commenter son comportement c'est un
comporte c'est à titre personnel là
qu'il en vient de commenter et moi je
suis là en tant que porte parole du
parti socialiste je ne suis pas là en
tant qu'individu l'abstention a été très
forte en pour cette élection vous le
disiez le déclare jean-luc pouteau que
ça a été dur avec 15% seulement des
inscrits est ce que ça signifie que la
démocratie est malade ou est ce qu'on
apprend là avec les candidats qui
étaient là c'est comment est-ce que vous
l'expliquer voilà justement on disait
que le fait qu'il fallait un
renouvellement politique et
treize candidats on avait le choix entre
-2 25% des électeurs tafer et cela veut
bien dire qu'il y a donc toujours ce
décalage entre la tante de la population
les messages portés par les politiques
et les réponses apportées par la
politique il ya un réel décalage qu'il
faut prendre en compte et il faut en
tirer les enseignements
cette tête ce nom d'intérêts vers la
sphère politique de la population est
vraiment apprendre en mesure pour les
échéances à venir
nous avons donc les européennes bientôt
les municipales il faut que le politique
réponde à ses attentes mais surtout
qu'elles comprennent les messages que
nous on voit que nous envoie la
population lorsque les échéances
électorales arrive c'est pas la première
fois que l'abstention est importante et
très importante elle elle grimpe à
chaque scrutin chaque scrutin dans les
politiques dire ouh là là c'est un
signal fort que nous envoie la
population il faut changer il faut se
dire et ne se passe rien ne se passe
alors je reprendrai cet exemple de la
gauche éparpillée 1
vous allez me dire que je suis chauvine
mais c'est bien cela si vous avez un
pléthore de candidats de gauche donc une
pléthore de projets comment se
retrouvent l'électeur de gauche face à
cela alors que sinon demain nous
n'avions eu une gauche unie
nous aurions eu un projet qui aurait eu
ni je pense les électeurs et les
électeurs de gauche les électeurs pro x
6 aurait pu se retrouver dans ce projet
unique chose qui n'a pas été fait
malheureusement s'il ya une dispersion
des candidats on imagine que c'est aussi
parce qu'une dispersion des idées des
projets des idéaux pas seulement une
question d'ego vendre on va revenir dans
le cours de cette émission sur sur le
positionnement idéologique du parti ou
mais malgré tout un premier mot là
dessus c'est s'il ya une semaine
autant de candidats c'est chaos une
impossibilité de s'entendre sur un
projet il ya cette impossibilité de
s'entendre et pourtant ce qu'il faut
retenir je pense c'est surtout cette
nécessité d'agir pour l'intérêt général
et non pas d'agir pour la victoire d'un
projet
les réunionnais les réunionnaises ont
besoin d'un projet qui porte leurs
attentes qui portent leurs espoirs
et s'ils ne participent pas c'est qu'ils
ont l'impression que le politique se
désintéresse de et de leurs attentes et
de leurs espoirs
il faut vraiment que l'on se remette en
question mais tous partis confondus le
parti socialiste est bien en
reconstruction pour cela parce que nous
sommes dans cette optique de travail et
de réfléchir d'échangé pour pouvoir
justement apporter des messages qui
parle à la population et répondre à ses
attentes
mais justement au niveau d'une vous êtes
vous êtes les héros c'est à dire
municipal vous êtes une élue de terrain
de nos bois de nèfles ça vous êtes au
contact j'imagine de temps en temps
régulièrement avec les citoyens avec des
administrés
qu'est-ce qui vous disent du monde
politique des élus au général côté en
général c'est beaucoup d'incompréhension
surtout après ses dernières
présidentielles qui voit là a laissé des
traces dans chacun des partis aussi vous
avez vu des bateaux afin d'aider des
personnes quitter le bateau dans dans
des parties ici et là donc différents
messages qui sont portés par des
personnes qui avaient des valeurs
communes
les gens sont perdus la population est
perdu et surtout surtout je pense
qu'elle elle est fatiguée de voir des
politiques qui se battent pour gagner
pour faire gagner leur parti pour pour
faire gagner si vous voulez une
idéologie et non pas faire gagner les
réunionnaises et les réunionnais je
pense que la population a à a réellement
besoin d'une nouvelle proximité avec
cette politique
la société évolue le monde évolue et les
attentes évoluent ce qu'on avait il ya
40 ans n'est pas forcément ce qui est en
demande aujourd'hui et donc nous devons
continuellement être à l'écouté de cette
population en évolution et adapter nos
réponses à ses attentes qui évolue
également
et aujourd'hui cette population ne
comprend pas que l'on puisse se bagarrer
je pense sur des positions et non pas se
bagarrer à défendre un territoire c'est
c'est vraiment cette incompréhension de
la population et cette peur d'avoir un
réel des intérêts du politique face à
leurs attentes
j'entends aussi je sais pas si c'est
votre cas mais moi j'entends aussi sur
le terrain une défiance méfiance
vis-à-vis des politiques du personnel
politique en dehors du positionnement
idéologique
avec par exemple cette idée que les
politiques sont là pour s'enrichir
a priori comment est-ce qu'on peut
lutter contre cette idée d'abord ce
qu'elle est fausse et et comment est-ce
qu'on peut lutter contre alors vous avez
déjà les prémices avec avec ces
nouvelles lois qui viennent donc régir
le nombre de mandats des élus je pense
que c'est une bonne chose et qu'il faut
continuer dans ce sens puisque
multiplier les casquettes pour un seul
et même homme un seul et même une seule
et même femme ans je dirais les gens ne
sont pas dans cette compréhension
il faudrait déjà que le politique
s'astreignent à faire la mission
première qui l'a souhaité à savoir
défendre l'intérêt général
défendre donc l'intérêt des populations
répondre à leur demande mais dans la
mission première qui le dans laquelle
ils s'inscrivent et malheureusement ce
n'est pas forcément le cas ce n'est pas
forcément le cas
et effectivement pensent les gens ont
cette tendance à dire que oui vous le
dit les politiques s'enrichissent malgré
la misère de la population
je pense que tout comme les personnes
les politiques ne sont pas tous à mettre
dans le même panier
de toute façon un politique reste un
individu avec sa personnalité avec ses
valeurs et il faut donc voir les projets
qu'ils portent
mais voir aussi le comportement qu'il a
les valeurs qu'ils qu'il souhaite
traduire dans ses projets je pense qu'il
est important de vraiment repartir dans
des débats idéologiques
ça fait longtemps qu'on n'en n'est pas
venu à cela donc on a vu lors des
dernières élections revenir ces fameux
débat à la télé avec vraiment des
oppositions idéologiques et ça permet de
relancer l'intérêt de la population face
à la halle à aux politiques le politique
part du principe souvent que les gens
peuvent tout comprendre tout tout de
suite mais malheureusement vous avez
souvent beaucoup technicité des propos
technocrates des choses qui sont pas
forcément
voilà
ah ah facile à comprendre et il faut
revenir sur des débats idéologiques mais
avec des mots simples ne plus prendre
plaisir à s'entendre parler mais prendre
du plaisir à expliquer à la population
pourquoi ce projet pourquoi faire comme
cela je pense que c'est ça qui est
important
pour revenir à cette question audrey
mais l'hymne de l'enrichissement des
élus opposants général ici la question
dans cette émission à chacun d'eux de ce
qu'ils gagnent comment est ce que vous
vous vivez ce que vous vivez aujourd'hui
de la politique suivie d'autres choses
et comment et combien haye comment et
combien alors non je ne suis que
conseillère municipale
donc je n'ai je n'ai qu'une indemnité de
débuts avec une délégation de territoire
donc ce n'est pas forcément grand chose
ça représente alors très exactement donc
moi je n'ai pas forcément de tablettes
sous 6 680 euros par mois vous l'aviez
dit tout à l'heure j'étais assistante
parlementaire de madame orphée
malheureusement lorsqu'elle n'a pas été
réélu mais mon contrat de travail est
tombé exactement donc à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui
enfin ça se dit pas ça se dit pas cette
expression au jour j'aime bien voilà
aujourd'hui donc je suis toujours je
suis inscrite dans une recherche
d'emploi
d'accord donc je vis pleinement l'aspect
sociétal du territoire vous avez été
nommé si mes informations sont correctes
c'est est relatée par nos confrères du
quotidien vous avez été nommée
présidente une société publique locale
qui s'appelle alors pour l'instant c'est
ça qui vous allez être venu expliquer sa
une à une une société publique locale
qui doit reprendre les activités
périscolaires de la ville de saint denis
où vous pourriez nous expliquer la mort
de quoi il s'agit alors donc la spl
c'est un outil nouveau un qui peut
permettre donc aux collectivités
d'optimiser
au mieux je dirais d'une manière
budgétaire son action sur le territoire
concrètement ça veut dire quoi société
publique locale ça veut dire que on
externalise c'est qu'on va fonctionner
comme une société privée alors vous avez
de l'argent que vous avez donc deux
communes qui on va dire qu'ils
s'associent pour créer cette société
publique locale donc saint denis et la
possession pour optimiser justement
l'action locale notamment dans cet
esprit elle en matière d'activités on va
dire périscolaire et de tout ce qui
tourne autour de l'éducation populaire
également
il était important vous savez à saint
denis je vais continuer à être chauvine
saint denis c'est une ville qui a pour
politique majeur l'éducation donc cela
fait déjà depuis son premier mandat que
que la ville de saint-denis s'investit
fortement dans en matière d'éducation en
essayant d'accompagner les écoles en
leur donnant le confort nécessaire pour
travailler mais surtout pour apporter
tout ce qu'il n'y a pas à l'école un
individu pour s'épanouir bien sûr il a
besoin d' apprendre l'orthographe la
grammaire les mathématiques l'histoire
mais malheureusement ça ne s'arrête pas
à cela un enfant pour s'épanouir il a
besoin au cid d'un apport culturel
il a aussi besoin d'un apport sportif s
qui a besoin pour gérer sa de créer une
société supplémentaires est ce que les
services de la mairie peuvent pas gérer
sans écouter jusqu'à maintenant c'était
donc des associations qui faisait ce
travail bien sûr ses associations
étaient bien sûr aidé par la ville mais
nous sommes dans une période de disette
je veux pas revenir là dessus nous à
nous sommes dans une période où les
dotations diminue et donc il fallait
optimiser les budgets et donc il était
pour nous un moyen d'optimiser ccc
budget et surtout de l'avoir réalisé
on espère que ça va coûter moins cher
c'est dans cette optique justement
d'avoir créé la spl c'est de pouvoir
ramener les fonds dans une seule et même
entité et non pas de les voir disperser
un petit peu partout et d'apporter sur
tout ce savoir faire et ses compétences
de les revaloriser ses savoir faire et
ses compétences associative de les
revaloriser
travers cet outil que sera donc au pays
il y aura on imagine un directeur pour
cette société publique locale vous en
serez la présidente alors normalement
c'est le conseil d'administration qui
doit voter donc pour l'instant je ne
suis que leur référente d'accord le
conseil municipal
on a acté la rive on a acté au très bel
hymne en tant que référence mais le
conseil d'administration devra donc voté
son président je suis candidat vous
toucheriez 3000 euros par mois pour ses
actions dans six là où ça deviendra
d'emplois ça deviendra un emploi est ce
qu'on a besoin de rémunérer les
présidents conseil administration dans
ces sociétés qui soit finalement géré
par leur direction a pas très
sincèrement c'est vrai que c'est quelque
chose qui me dérange dans le sens où
lorsque saint denis a évoqué cette spl
cet outil nouveau n'en avons pas encore
à la réunion
d'ailleurs c'est novateur de faire une
espèce dans l'éducation c'est pour
montrer déjà notre notre investissement
certain en matière d'éducation
mais c'est surtout que j'ai souhaité
participer à la genèse de ce projet et
je ne compte pas m'investir uniquement
en apposant mais signature en fin de
mois
j'ai vraiment envie j'ai eu pour mission
excusez-moi de de participer à la
construction de cette spl d'en poser le
cadre de l'aider à se développer et
c'est une mission que je souhaite
remplir et je pense que lorsqu'il y à
une jeune femme qui a quatre ans
d'expérience en politique
certes je suis jeune mais je pense que
c'est ce n'est pas parce que c'est une
jeune femme qui va prendre la présidence
d'une spl qu'il faut taper dit qu'il
faut lui taper sur les doigts
moi je je pense que c'est une belle
ouverture pour pour les faits les femmes
en politique c'est une responsabilité en
tout cas que je me sens capable de
prendre parce que j'ai envie d'y
travailler dit travailler réellement
quels ont été les mesures que la
municipalité a dû prendre justement pour
le périscolaire sachant
vous l'avez dit la baisse des dotations
la baisse des contrats aidés
ça veut dire qu'elle des choses dans
lesquelles il a fallu trancher il a
fallu se séparer renoncer à certaines
certes un accompagnement périscolaire il
ya eu bien sûr une der fléchage mais le
maximum a été fait en matière
d'éducation
donc nous avions déjà pour mission
durant ces vacances de juillet août de
procéder à ce dédoublement des fameuses
classes de ce1
donc on sait astreignez à le faire
pendant les vacances donc on a eu une
rentrée donc avec les fameuses classes
de ce1 à 12 dans les rep irait plus de
saint denis
donc nous sommes tenus à cette mission
en termes de périscolaire
d'accompagnement périscolaire sera
illuminé des choses qui ont dû être
abandonnées
on a du sein on a dû s'aligner aussi sur
cette nouvelle emploi du temps donc nous
étions paravent sur quatre jours n'est
plus une demi journée d'école est donc
un apport périscolaire
on va dire en format plus plus le
mercredi après midi effectivement c'est
quelque chose qui a disparu
enfin disparu pour être réadapté
réinvesti envers ses activités
périscolaires c'est mercredi jeunesse la
spl a pour vocation d'optimiser cela et
surtout de revaloriser ses compétences
lorsque vous êtes salarié dans une
association souvent une association est
un peu sous perfusion en fait des
subventions allouées pour le maintien de
son activité
nous ce que l'on voulait c'était
vraiment apporté une consolidation de
cela j'hibernais dit souvent que sa
priorité vous l'avez dire c'est
l'éducation la formation des jeunes
pourtant le chômage et l'illettrisme
reste très haut qu'est ce que vous dites
vous aux jeunes que vous croisez dans
votre quartier et qui aujourd'hui peine
à trouver un emploi une formation
c'est extrêmement compliqué déjà il faut
il faut prendre le temps de discuter
avec ne peut pas le faire en cinq
minutes entre dans entre dans parmi des
audiences moi ce que personnellement en
tant qu'ils luttent secteur ce que
j'aime bien faire cesser de les voir en
milieu de semaine généralement et non
pas en jours d'audience le samedi matin
puisque souvent répète que les mairies
de saint denis
ouverte le samedi matin pour les
audiences avec les élus mois moi je
préfère les rencontrer en semaine pour
surtout écouter leur parcours de vie
leur parcours scolaire et l'espoir
qu'ils ont et discuter avec eux sur le
fait que ce n'est pas parce que cette
histoire leur semble très éloignée de la
réalité qui ne peuvent pas y parvenir
le gros souci de la jeunesse à la
réunion c'est qu'avec cette société avec
cette évolution avec cette
surconsommation les médias internet
tout va très très vite tout va très très
vite chez les jeunes et souvent on se
retrouva à être orientée pas forcément
d'une bonne façon aussi en fin de
parcours scolaire ont sonné dans des
désillusions et il faut vraiment prendre
le temps de les re motiver leur redonner
envie de leur redonner de l'espoir
souvent s'ils sont perdus c'est parce
qu'ils ont perdu espoir et notre travail
- en tant qu il eut cédé re motiver les
faits rares est allé sur les rails oui
de la formation j'ose le dire il ya eu
des places en formation il ya de
l'emploi alors proposé vous avez des
secteurs d'emploi qui sont ouverts
est-ce qu'il faut qu'on me met
malheureusement être alors c'est la rue
pour accepter alors ça s'est vérifié en
plus cette histoire je suis pas si vous
le savez mais ça s'est vérifié et
finalement il n'y avait qu'un bistrot
qui avait une place de disponible
mais non ça va être très compliqué on
est sur un marché très concurrentiel
c'est vraiment une grande bagarre d'être
sur le marché du travail c'est les
meilleurs qui gagnent donc il faut
savoir se vendre et l'éducation
nationale telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui ne prépare pas les jeunes à
se vendre sur le territoire en tout cas
sur le marché du travail
autre bulle immo vous allez devenir
c'est la triste je serai sénatrice riz
c'est incompatible avec la présidence
d'une spl est bien pour l'instant mon
mandat ne commencerait qu'en septembre
ces trois premières années appartiennent
donc à michel dennemont donc il est
libre de mener cette mandature cette c3
première année de mandature
avec ça vous étiez nommé président tout
spl dans trois ans vous vous abandonner
son mandat
écoutez moi la mission que j'ai très
sincèrement c'est de mener à bien
hop et de la faire vivre de la faire se
développer
et s'il faut que je laisse ma place pour
prendre ce mandat il n'y a pas de souci
pourvu que halo reach sur cela la
priorité c'est les engagements que j'ai
pris et le premier engagement de ces
prix c'était bien cette mandature
depuis le début de votre accord certains
observateurs assurent que vous
n'occuperait jamais ce fauteuil que vous
laisserez votre place à christian
annette qui est le suivant sur la liste
qu'est ce que vous leur dites vous vous
engagez ici à ne pas démissionner à
prendre ce poste des écoutes et
personnellement je trouve ça bien
dommage que lorsqu'une femme à chaque
fois s'il s'agit d'une femme
ça m'étonne parce que quand c'est des
sommes à chaque fois il n'y a pas autant
de la pas autant de si je peux me
permettre de commérages tour ça vient
pas de concept et cetera et cetera
effectivement non moi j'ai j'ai fait
campagne
j'ai fait campagne pour un binôme michel
dennemont audrey bel hymne donc en 2020
septembre 2020 je l'honorerai mon mandat
de sénatrice
tout à fait quels sont aujourd'hui vos
relations avec michel dennemont
elle sera envoyée aux 3l sont courtoises
nous avions donc pour proposer dès le
départ des axes de travail commun donc
il s'y tient après nous n'avons pas la
même sensibilité politique ça cela
c'était acté dès le départ et c'est bien
pour ça que je le dis il a toute cette
liberté de mener ses trois premières
années comme il le souhaite puisque moi
je mènerai mais trois les trois
dernières années comme je le souhaite
vous convenez que mon activité politique
y compris pour les électeurs ça puisse
être un peu compliqué à comprendre
qu'ils ont voté alors ils ont élu alors
c'est pas un vote directement les
d'accord mais mais ils sont quand même
c'est quand même le suffrage
finalement au final des citoyens qui
s'exprime on a là un binôme avec un
michel dennemont lpa très proches des
mariés le maquereau qui est et maniema
croire besoin de son vote au sénat
et puis après on va avoir une sénatrice
socialiste qui va dans l'opposition lors
des négociations michel dennemont ne
s'était pas prononcée tel qu'il se
prononce aujourd'hui d'une part et de
deux je le répète et je me répète
énormément là dessus cela ne me pose
aucun problème dans la semaine et les
joueurs se comprendre et les électeurs
ça puisse être un os bien sûr compliqué
à suivre le fil et en même temps lors
des sénatoriales l'objectif c'était de
faire barrage au candidat encore une
fois de la droite et notamment de la
droite qu'incarner didier robert il
allait faire si nous n'avions pas
présenté ce binôme il allait
certainement faire un carton plein et
avoir quatre sénateurs pour représenter
le territoire de la réunion et on
n'aurait pas été forcément dans une
démocratie les sensibilités politiques
n'auraient pas été tout même si là je ne
représente pas toutes les possibilités
sensibilités politiques mais en tout cas
l'objectif c'était bien d'amener une
alternative à ces trois candidats c'est
cette liste de droite c'était vraiment
de présenter une réalité alternative
aujourd'hui effectivement peut-être que
les électeurs ont du mal à se retrouver
dans cette association
mais c'est bien lui nomme avec deux
temps demanda totalement distinct est
différent donc oui deux sensibilités
politiques
la preuve même que les parties
progressif peuvent donc se retrouver
lorsqu'il s'agit de défendre l'intérêt
général et cela avait été donc le cas
lors des sénatoriales
7 ce rassemblement cette réunion que
nous avons eue entre le npa et le parti
socialiste s'était bien d'apporter une
alternative pour l'intérêt général comme
intermède musical vous avez choisi
audrey bel hymne born to die de lana del
rey on l'écouté puis on vous expliquera
après pourquoi vous avez choisi cette
musique merci
[Musique]
c'est
en juin
à
[Musique]
c
itunes
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
et ça
quand on
ça
dans
son nom
[Musique]
oh
simple
c'est
[Musique]
les moments
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
désolé en être obligés de couper cette
musique on va l'écouter on perd du temps
d'entretien avec vous audrey belimo
drilling a donc choisi lana del rey born
to die pourquoi cette chanson c'est un
peu triste c'est très triste c'est vrai
que ça vous ressemblent ou non ça me
ressemble pas forcément ce que ce que
j'aime dans cette chanson c'est bien là
mais là la mélodie la mélancolie le flou
elle mélange le pop le folk un petit peu
de hip hop aussi c'est très vintage
lorsqu'on regarde le clip et mais ça
parle d'amour c'est très noir mais ça
parle d'amour et ça parle d'espoir et
donc pour moi c'est une très belle
chanson qu'est ce qui vous a amené vous
jeune dionysienne autres minima faire de
la politique ce que vous étiez dans
l'ombre en tant qu'attaché parlement ça
y est vous la lumière en étant candidate
notamment pour ses pour ces sénatoriales
mais déjà avant sur la liste pour les
municipales et pour le conseil
départemental qu'est ce qui vous a amené
voit faire ça je peux être franche avec
vous alors c'est ma maternité en fait
c'est le fait d'avoir une petite fille
qui m'a donné envie de m'impliquer
politiquement je finissais mes études je
finissais mon master en métropole et
suite à l'obtention de mon diplôme j'ai
quand même essuyé trois ans et demi de
chômage en venant d'une femme qui était
corrigé de 2,3 des études de droit oui
c'était une faute côté j'étais à lyon
jean moulin et et on me disait pareil à
travers ses orientations scolaires tu
verras au sortir de jean moulin tout les
office notarial tous les cabinets
d'huissier tous les cabinets d'avocats
t'ouvrir ont les bras
tu viens de lyon iii c'est très coté et
malheureusement on venant de lyon 3 eh
bien j'ai quand même fait trois ans et
demi de chômage et puis et puis j'ai eu
un bébé à la fin de ses études et alors
que je cherchais du travail et que
qu'elle avait à peine un enjeu j'ai
commencé à m'inquiéter pour son avenir à
elle en fait je me suis dit c'est c'est
triste quoi j'ai fait tant d'années
d'études j'ai fait tant de sacrifices
parce que faire des études quitté la
réunion c'est aussi bien quitter ses
amis quitter sa famille lorsqu'on est
étudiant en métropole moi je n'étais pas
boursière donc j'ai travaillé
en même temps donc j'ai travaillé au
mcdo j'ai travaillé comme comme
caissière j'ai fait les vendanges pour
pouvoir voilà c'est ici que vous avez du
mal à trouver du travail en métropole
aussi en métropole aussi je suis resté
pendant un an en métropole à la fin de
mon diplôme pour chercher du travail
et puis je suis tombée enceinte et donc
je suis rentré à la réunion et c'est
vraiment versé ses 18 monts 18-24 mois
où je me suis dit d'un pétard il faut
faire quelque chose quoi je ne peux pas
rester dans cette société qui reste
inerte face à toutes ces compétences à
ses flux de cerveau moi j'ai plein de
j'ai plein d'amis de fac qui ne sont
plus à la réunion et qui ne sont même
plus en métropole il faut privilégier
l'embauché locale et y compris
l'inscrire dans la loi éventuellement
alors ça va être fort de café de dire de
priviligier embauches locales
je dirais plutôt qu'il faut regarder si
on a les compétences ici sur notre
territoire avant d'aller les chercher
ailleurs parce qu'on a mais pas
forcément l'inscrire dans la loi ces
saucisses et sans fermer ses samples
avait aussi un ça peut être dangereux un
2-2 d'avoir peur de l'extérieur je pense
qu'il faut un juste milieu
il faut un juste milieu il faut donner
la chance aux territoires avant d'aller
voir ailleurs
en tout cas gilbert annette monique
orphé ericka bareigts ge dans une
moindre mesure ont été très clairement
des soutiens des manuels macron pendant
sa campagne présidentielle
comment est-ce que vous situer
aujourd'hui ce que vous restez comme
gilbert annette très macro compatibles
ou comerica barrage qui elle très
clairement dans l'opposition
alors en tant que porte parole du parti
je suis dans une opposition certes
constructive tout comme tout comme les
la nouvelle constructive on ne peut pas
jeter ce qui est bon ccpcc 1 à 12 c'est
une bonne chose par exemple nous à saint
denis qui nous inscrivons dans une
politique en matière d'éducation très
forte
c'est une mesure qu'on a accueilli
favorablement et donc on s'est dépêché
pendant ces vacances de juillet août et
saine
la suppression de l'abattement fiscal
30% c'est une bonne nouvelle ça c'est
une moins bonne nouvelle c'est une -
même si ce n'est que les plus riches
finalement ça ce que ça peut être de la
redistribution est quand même resté les
4%
ça reste 4 % oui d'aidé au revenu mais
on commence à s'attaquer un peu à la
classe moyenne
moi je dirais que après avoir fait des
cadeaux aux riches et très riches
après avoir attaqué sur attaquer les
petites les petites retraites après
avoir attaqué les demandeurs d'emploi en
supprimant les contrats aidés en allant
sur un quasi gel des revalorisations des
allocations familiales des pensions de
retraite de l'aide au logement
et bien maintenant on est en train de
s'attaquer à la classe moyenne la place
moyenne
c'est une classe qui pète tout elle n'a
pas dette de l'état donc venir à nouveau
pressurisée sur ces hauts revenus certes
mais ça reste quand même la classe
moyenne moi je dis qu'il faudrait
peut-être arrêter de de s'attaquer aux
plus faibles et d'aller regarder au plus
haut les suppressions de postes dans la
fonction publique essentiellement pour
le ministère des comptes publics
l'éducation nationale
et même à croire mais promis de
supprimer 120 mille postes dans la
fonction publique c'est pas vraiment une
surprise c'est pas une surprise
vous êtes font écouter lorsque je vois
que l'on s'attaque à au poste du
ministère des sports
1600 postes de cts en moins moi ça me
fait peur donc les y est vous avez donc
et on l'entend bien à l'époque où vous
l'avez soutenu il annoncé la couleur
mais mais voilà c'est au derrière cela
vous avez des choix des ministères qui
sont sanctuarisés qu'on ne touche pas et
des ministères donc qu'ils prennent
plein pot et c'est ce qui est arrivé au
ministère des sports avec quand même
cette lettre de cadrage qui rappelle
donc la suppression des cinquante mille
postes de fonctionnaires donc ça fait
peur quelles sont donc finalement les
priorités de ce gouvernement
vers où souhaitent ils allaient de
l'élection qu'on se pose l'armée donc
tout ce qui touche un peu à la proximité
et donc c'est dommage
c'est vraiment dommage donc lorsqu'on
touche à la proximité on va s'attaquer
finalement directement à la population
et donc cela veut dire que l'abstention
ne va pas ne va pas désenflé la
transformation du cic en baisse de
charge ça va coûter 40 milliards d'euros
baisse d'impôt sur les sociétés
ça c'est une politique qui avait été
initié volant dans le par françois
hollande elle n'a pas forcément donné
beaucoup de résultats en termes de
création d'emplois est ce que malgré
tout il faut continuer dans cette voie
là écoutez je pense qu'il fallait
continuer dans cette voie là les
nouvelles mesures qui sont annoncées
dans ce projet de loi de finances elles
sont peur dans le sens où elles sont
fléchés elles sont fléchés sur certains
secteurs d'activité
donc cela veut dire encore une fois
qu'il ya donc des secteurs 100k risée et
qu'il ya des secteurs qui sont laissés
pour compte
c'est ces petits secteurs là qui qui qui
vont gronder
qui vont donc en prendre plein pot c'est
extrêmement inquiétant
en tout cas pour pour la situation
économique de la réunion
est ce que madame girardin a conscience
de nos spécificités de notre tissu
économique qui est constituée à 90% 92%
même de tpm donc vraiment ce qui est
dommage c'est que leurs réflexions sont
restés uniquement au niveau des budgets
il n'y a pas eu de réflexion stratégique
n'y a pas eu
mais en même temps c'est en même temps
il faut bien faire des économies quelque
part il faut faire des économies quelque
part mais fausse une question ne faut
pas penser qu'au budget il faut aussi
penser aux assauts projet que l'on
souhaite mener au développement que l'on
souhaite apporter et aux enjeux qui nous
attendent
donc lorsque vous avez un jeu reprend le
sport lorsque vous avez soit disant un
gouvernement pro européen et pourtant
lorsque vous avez le sport qui est acté
dans ce fameux livre brand la commission
européenne comme facteur d'intégration
vecteur d'insertion sociale qui reprit
encore le sport comme facteur
d'insertion vecteur d'intégration
sociale par le plan pluriannuel de lutte
contre la pauvreté
donc où est ce que l'on s'inscrit ou est
ce que le gouvernement s'inscrit c'est
en cela que c'est inquiétant sur
quelques sujets je voudrais bien avoir
votre votre sentiment l'interdiction du
glyphosate ce qu'il aurait dû être
inscrit dans la loi vous auriez voter
vous pour son inscription dans la loi
les députés socialistes ont brillé par
leur absence
non je n'aurais pas je ne pense pas que
ça soit forcément le sujet qui intéresse
les français et les françaises encore
une fois le gouvernement va dans des
réflexions extrêmement technique elle
s'astreint à tout ce qui est budgétaire
et la population décroche enfin là nous
décroche là il est question d'écologie
il est question d'agriculture ce sont
des questions importantes la démission
de nicolas hulot exact en ligne et c'est
important de se positionner par rapport
à votre électorat sur ce genre de
questions là
faut-il aujourd'hui dès aujourd'hui
inscrire l'interdiction du glyphosate
dans la loi mais je pense qu'il aurait
été important en tout cas qu'on entame
cette réflexion il aurait important
qu'on le fasse
alors qu'on parle donc de ces gens je de
développement durable il est important
qu'on en parle
lorsqu'on parle d'écologie alors que
lorsqu'on parle de ce turn over qui
s'opère donc sur la société et sur les
territoires
je pense que oui il était important
qu'on rentre dans cette réflexion assez
rapidement et un sujet qui dont on parle
assez peu ici parce qu on est loin pour
l'instant de la question mais l'aquarius
c'est un bateau qui sauve des migrants
méditerranée et qui les sauve de la
noyade souvent les ramène dans des ports
européens aujourd'hui le bateau n'a plus
de papillons
la france doit-elle faire un geste
doit-elle s'impliquer accueillir plus
facilement ces migrants
cette question d'accueil des migrants
elle est très sensible effectivement non
la france la france et s'est toujours
inscrite dans cette cette politique
d'accueil
je pense que oui il faut qu'on il ne
faut pas compte toujours encore une fois
qu'on sent clave et rester entre nous
bien sûr qu'on doit être bienveillant et
s'ouvrir mais cela doit être bien pensée
on ne peut pas la rupture est encore une
fois brutal et je pense que les migrants
s'ils quittent leur territoire c'est
bien parce qu'ils sont en souffrance
chez eux
la france est un eldorado donc bien sûr
on ne peut pas accueillir tout le monde
mais cela n'empêche que l'on ne peut pas
fermer toutes les portes j'aimerais
qu'on revienne très rapidement
s'aggraver en fin d'émission sur le
positionnement du ps dont vous êtes ici
là la porte parole gilbert annette qui
est si proche de la politique du
gouvernement si en accord avec l peut-il
rester au ps est ce que est ce que ce
sont sans exclusion est envisagé annonce
une exclusion n'est pas on n'est pas sur
ce débat à gilbert annette continuent à
venir au parti il est socialiste
non gilbert annette sein des insurgés
s'inscrit sur une politique locale et
et vous avez un débat après nationale
localement parlant encore une fois
lorsque vous avez des mesures en matière
d'éducation qui vont dans le sens de la
politique de saint denis
il ne peut que s'inscrire et accueillir
cela favorablement mais cela ne veut pas
dire qu'il claque la porte au parti
socialiste
en tout cas je ne l'ait pas entendu à
dire cela il ya au moins dix socialistes
demandent un positionnement clair par
rapport à la politique du gouvernement
était jusqu'à alors plus qu'ambiguë pour
l'instant ceux qui souhaitaient quitter
le bâton quitté le bateau et je pense
que ce sont des questions qui doivent
être posées à gilbert annette
on peut avoir vous en tant que porte
parole vous comment est ce que vous
allez régler ce grand écart à défendre
en même temps la parole de certains qui
sont très proches du gouvernement et
puis d'autres qui sont proches peut-être
de benoît hamon qui avait remporté la
primaire pour la paix je pense qu'il
faut que les gens aient conscience que
gilbert annette stress le maire de la
première ville d'outre-mer et qu'avant
tout il doit mener une bonne gestion de
sa commune et lorsque vous avez donc des
mesures qui facilite son projet
politique
donc il a donc les moyens de favoriser
ces mesures qui qui vont dans le sens de
son projet politique et de développement
de son territoire en matière d'éducation
il faut bien faire la part des choses
lorsque vous avez un gilbert annette qui
se prononce pour la commune de saint
denis et lorsque vous avez un gilbert
annette qui parle au nom du parti ou
lorsqu'il prend sa casquette politique
il faut bien faire cette distinction
effectivement oui c'est complexe peut
être aux yeux des électeurs mais nous en
tout cas la fédération nous sommes bien
au fait de cela comment est-ce qu'on
reconstruit la gauche réunionnaise ce
qu'il faut la reconstruire à gauche
est-ce qu'il faut la reconstruire avec
eux le plr le pcr la france a soumis
europe ecologie les verts ou est ce
qu'il faut aller vers la république en
marche non je pense que déjà nous devons
appeler la gleague de la gauche à s'unir
à s'entendre à engager des discussions
donc le fait d'avoir ces échéances qui
arrivent celle de du 7e 17e
circonscription
vous avez également les européennes qui
vont arriver bientôt puis les nuits
cipal nous sommes obligés d'entrer dans
une réflexion de rassemblement encore
une fois vous pour que vous arrivez par
exemple de robert on ne sait pas nous
nous restons nous sommes un parti
progressiste
et nous restons dans cette ligne de
conduite nous restons unis face aux
partis progressistes et effectivement
nous ne pouvons fermer les portes à cela
éparpillés la gauche c'est faire perdre
les réunionnais faire perdre les
réunionnaises donc moi j'appelle
vraiment à aux partis aux différents
partis à ses électeurs et vain d'entrer
en discussion d'entrer dans cette
réflexion de rassemblement de la gauche
pour faire gagner non pas un parti ou
une sensibilité politique
mais pour faire gagner des territoires
vous serez ou dans dix ans écoutez dans
dix ans alors j'espère pouvoir
travailler dans ma danse que je prépare
actuellement j'aimerais je suis en train
de préparer mon cas pas pour devenir
avocate donc j'espère que dans dix ans
je pourrais donc exercer en tant
qu'avocate politiquement j'espère
toujours m'investir j'ai toujours envie
de m'investir et de m'engager je pense
que c'est une passion qui va me tenir
pendant encore très longtemps mais je
n'ai pas besoin d'exister médiatiquement
pour continuer à faire de la politique
en tout cas personne n'a besoin de cela
quand on aime de la politique quand on a
un vrai sens de l'intérêt général
on n'a pas besoin d'exister pour ça il
suffit de travailler et de s'investir
entre temps vous serez passer par un
mandat de sénatrice vous nous confirmer
aujourd'hui que l'exercice ne devrait
pas c'est un engagement que j'ai pris en
2017 et que je tiendrais en 2000 merci
beaucoup d'avoir été massive array vite
ce soir
dans quelques secondes les infos ensuite
ce sera elodie pour une émission
spéciale dédiée à charles aznavour dont
on appris le décès cet après midi passé
une excellente soirée sur la première
[Musique]
lundi politique
gaël le dantec il ya des sujets qui font
débat le chantier de la route du
littoral opinion qui divergent je ne
suis pas d'accord analyse qui diffère à
cannes prendre ses responsabilités et
pour se faire sa propre opinion
c'est toujours intéressant d'écouter les
arguments les uns et des autres
spécialistes responsables et l'uil sont
invités à confronter leurs convictions
le débat du mardi le magazine de la
rédaction
tous les mardis à 18h15 sur la première
vous écoutez la première il est 19
heures voici les titres du journal de
france info 100 millions de disques
vendus l'an 70 ans de carrière et des
chansons qu'on le connaît tous par coeur
dans le monde entier
la mort de charles aznavour m émeut la
france entière toute la classe politique
des communistes au front national en
passant par la république en marche lui
rend hommage la ministre de la culture
par exemple françoise nyssen évoque une
véritable légende qui a traversé les
frontières et les époques ses pairs
artistes font tous part de leur
tristesse cet après midi cela me fait
une peine énorme j'ai envie de pleurer
réaction hôtellerie comme assia sur
france info benjamin biolay parle de la
mort du vrai boss d'un guide d'un maître
julien clerc patrick bruel maxime le
forestier
tous saluent le talent immense du
dernier géant de la chanson française
interprète bien sûr la bohème emmenez
moi je me voyais déjà la mama for me